Marx Lera --the was on the call with
dick Stockton's yesterday called in this
game he joins us now mark how are you
I'm good and if there's anybody that
knows pretending it's Richard Sherman
for saying that Baker Mayfield was a
game so he's the expert on pretending
okay what did you did you need to see
something yesterday to be all in on the
Niners no I mean I've watched you know I
watched their films of prepared and so I
had watched what they have done
defensively I've watched what they've
done in the running game and so I knew
that this is a good football team they
control the line of scrimmage on both
sides of the ball they're one of the
most unique teams when it comes to
running the ball and I think Charles
Shanahan has proven to be in my mind one
of the best coaches of the NFL and I
think what separates him is he
understands all 22 and the problems are
the issues that every position has and I
think he does a great job of telling his
people and telling his players what
we're going to do but more importantly
why we're going to do it and then how
it's going to benefit you in the long
run so I think he gets by in where a lot
of other coaches don't get the same
buy-in based on on the way baby
so like this this team is they're good
football team and I'm unlike you in that
Jimmy Garoppolo has to prove to me that
he can stay healthy was my biggest issue
with Jimmy but they're they're a really
good football team there's no question
about that
as many years as you played and you know
it doesn't take long for the league or
defensive coordinators to get a book on
offenses or vice versa you know
offensive coordinator get a book on a
defense and figure them out have
defenses figured out the Rams well to a
degree one of the things that's happened
to the Rams is you go back to last
season in Detroit that at some Chicago
did it some and then you know the
Masterclass was the new gone Patriots
and there's been a lot of cut and paste
game plans from the Patriots in the
Super Bowl where they held the Rams down
to three
points a lot of cut-and-paste off of
that stuff to kind of shut down some of
that jet sweep and some of that illusion
of complexity that has been the Rams the
Rams were able to dictate for several
years offensively to defenses and right
now they're dictating to the Rams the
defense they're dictating the Rams and
so that's been a change I think one of
the other things that has happened to
the Rams is they lost 2/5 of their
starting offensive line and they replace
them with players that aren't as good
and that are young and aren't as
experienced and that's hurt them a
little bit as well so there's kind of a
perfect storm here if you will of what
they're facing is something that they
like I said that they haven't prepared
for during the week because everybody's
just taking a piece of that game plan
from the New England Patriots and just
kind of putting it in so they work all
week about you know preparing to play a
defense that's going to do one thing and
then they have to adjust on the
sidelines they certainly haven't
adjusted as well over the course of this
season as you would hope and and part of
that is because they've got some new
pieces some new components and and
obviously they haven't figured out
exactly how to adjust of the way the
defensive fronts and the structures that
they're getting on a consistent basis
who's your MVP at this point yeah you
know I'd I'd probably put it with
Russell Wilson some of the things that
he is that he has done not only you know
and it every down situation but the
second-chance players or the second
reaction plays what he means to the
Seattle Seahawks what he means to that
offense is probably with if you're
breaking it down is most valuable he's
probably there's nobody more valuable to
their football team than Russell Wilson
is the Seattle Seahawks who is the
second best team in the AFC Wow yeah you
know it feels like Houston to me right
now is probably the second-best team but
you know like every team is in it right
what is whether 16 teams in the AFC
you're all in it everybody still got a
chance to make the playoffs that you
know week six were through
it seems like and Broncos just won a
game to go two and four and it feels to
me like they're still in this playoff on
their in this they they play Kansas City
on Thursday night this Thursday night
they win that game and their one game
out of first place in their division it
seems like everybody's in it we're
talking to mark flair with Fox Sports
NFL analyst a three times Super Bowl
champ if I put it up to a player's vote
and I said you could vote for get rid of
instant replay get rid of it completely
or keep it as is how do you think the
players would vote I'll get rid of it
yeah that's my feeling mark because I
give you a chance to replay the replay
and they're still getting things wrong
and I don't I just don't understand that
that it feels like they don't want to
embarrass the officials well I've always
said this one and they put in instant
replay and then they tell the officials
hey make sure you swallow your whistles
and let instant replay figure it out
right and I think it's created guys who
are less sure of themselves you know
guys who are less demonstrative and then
I think you're asking them to do things
that are just physically impossible to
do so I think all those things kind of
add up and it slows down the game I mean
he'll every like every time you use
every time there's a big play every time
there's an explosive play the first
thing I do is I check my monitor after
after we're done calling the play
looking for a flag is there a flag
what's going to happen is there a
penalty what's going on and there's a
bunch of things like I keep getting
these rules where well you can't you
can't review that one
like that's reviewable that one's not
reviewable and that's reviewable to that
one's not we can't reverse that one
because I'm just like just scrap pile
the whole thing let's just play the game
and just understand that mistakes are
part of it and and the best teams are
gonna win yeah I we keep thinking maybe
offensive and defensive lineman wearing
mittens because there there was a moment
in the Cowboys Jets game yesterday in
the final drive I think there were six
or seven consecutive penalties and I
just went at some point they have to
know this is bad for
there's no flow to a game anymore and it
didn't get better we overreacted to the
miss Kohl in the Saints game that's
that's why we're here and and I just I
don't think they've made the product
better this year they made it worse no
and I think it'll go away and and by the
way you know the officials essentially
are being told like you like we're not
gonna overrule you anymore I mean that's
that's where we are right now so even if
it is blatant I wish seen some blatant
you know past interference OPI or DPI's
that are called that you go back and you
think there's no way this is going to be
upheld and then you know they they don't
they uphold it anyway they're like yeah
we're gonna scrap pile this in the end
anyhow so we're not gonna overturn
anything I'm with you the whole thing is
somewhat of a debacle
but listen holding happens as long as
it's away from the play who cares
hey my theory is this dan and I live by
this and I'm old offensive lineman but
don't get help right if you get held you
suck don't get help how many times you
think you got called for holding in your
career I don't know probably less than a
dozen really yeah that's pretty good
yeah you know I mean I probably averaged
one or two one well I want a year I
think I had because I had a couple zero
holding call years I think in my six
years in Denver I had six holding goals
could you ever talk your way out is it
like you know with the police officer
talking your way out of a speeding
ticket or do you just shut up well I
would I would talk my way out of it
before I actually before the game I used
to go to the umpire every game and be
like listen dude they're bigger faster
stronger on this you realize that right
and so then I would be like listen I am
gonna hold I am gonna molest this guy
I'm gonna hold on every single play but
my hands will be inside because my hands
are great and they'll be inside and I go
you cannot throw a flag on that like I
am going to undress this dude but you
cannot throw a flag on that as long as
my hands are inside
let them know exactly how they should
how they should officiate me like here's
the rules for officiating me and it
actually worked pretty well you know I
mean for the most part they I would even
get warning sometimes like hey slurred
you a little bit outside on that your
hands are the last minute this is your
warning warning oh yeah all the time I
talk of blue street to him I'll leave
you with this when should Browns fans
start to panic now why is that I
probably should hey the influential
broadcaster I probably should instead of
a fun game do you have any Browns games
on the schedule
always to talk to enjoyed listening to
you in dick Stockton's yesterday thank
you mark buddy take care
marks Larry I don't know how many
surgeries he had he had over 20 I think
like whenever I'd feel bad about all my
surgeries all I do is I'd run into
Slayer that ESPN and then he would tell
me all the knee surgeries he had is it
just me or slurred getting goofier right
getting goofier for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]